the man who I could refer to is one of
the greatest fielders of all time a
World Series champion an Emmy
award-winning broadcaster one of the
best that we have right now on Sportsnet
New York but I can also introduce this
man as the the dad of [ __ ] he's Keith
Hernandez here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Keith I'm great how are you
which which would you prefer to be known
as Keith out of all those I just
mentioned well I guess I'm stuck with
the father of [ __ ] where do we start
with that how did you come up with what
is [ __ ] rescue
first off Keith it's [ __ ] arrest no no
no no no I did a highly bred cat is a
Bengal the cat and I use 15 years old
I've had him for a very long time and
his his his name originates from the
Jonny Quest cartoon and the Bengal
Bengal cat is also Bengal is the
province of the subcontinent in India
India and the friend of Johnny Quest a
cartoon character was a subcontinent
Indian named [ __ ] so it was perfect and
then just getting the paper now I know
what you look like getting the paper
I've been I've been I've been seeing all
this stuff Keith what would have been
like if you had Twitter when you
actually played
I think it would have made things
infinitely more difficult for me I
probably would not have had a Twitter
feed our twiddle Twitter handle when I
played it would have been too
distracting so it's been kind of fun now
I mean I don't understand why the
players have them I mean but that's just
the way the world has changed with
social media and it's been kind of an
eye-opener with me it's but kind of
funny because my kids I have three
daughters and they're all off of social
media and I never was and now they're
off and I'm on your girls are not on
social media but you are now dad is no
but they've but they plug into my handle
and they follow me but they don't get
involved I see
and then what I gotta get your thought
when you're looking out in the stands
and now you see big big big heads of
[ __ ] being held up by fans in Atlanta I
might add I saw that Keith yeah I mean
you said it's fairly amazing I started
to handle just basically to promote the
book yes and I have an apparel line too
and it just once I took on G for the
walk for the newspaper in the video and
I just learned to do a video so that's
what I did one of the first ones I did
and that went viral
I went within four days I had like
30,000 followers and now it's over 70 in
building so I'm enjoying it I like to
write I know instagrams a lot a lot of
people like Instagram better but it's
more photographs yes I've always loved
to write and I liked and typed I took
typing in high school and that's
probably one of the best classes almost
formula I ever took as far as going
forward in my life but I've always loved
to write and it's so I enjoy the Twitter
Keith Hernandez here on the Rich Eisen
show at Keith Hernandez on Twitter and I
just before we move on to the book I do
need to say the clothing line is for
humans not cats right Keith
it's for humans and it even has onesies
for human babies can I get can I get so
I can get a nice game pretty boy t-shirt
on you can't do anything sign so that's
all boy they've got that you gotta pay
an arm and a leg for anything that
anything when I can't even use I'm Keith
Hernandez which would be a great put
t-shirt but but it's on the guy you have
to get permission it's the name of your
book though no I think that maybe Little
Brown paid the price oh I don't know I'm
not sure okay but I'm sure you reach I'm
yeah how often do you speak to Jerry I
mean I'm sure I'm sure he's right right
there all the time right he's out here
and he's out in East Hampton and I'm in
Sag Harbor so he's got his own life and
it becomes of the ballpark he's got his
he's a Mets fan he's got his his his
sweet and we've had him in the booth a
couple times right and I think it should
be an annual thing but you know he's got
his own life he's raising kids and I've
got mine I work you know the baseball
life it's on night games and everybody's
having dinner I'm at the ballpark in the
first inning that's right
and please tell me Keith that you have
helped Jerry move in real life did you
do that
I wish I could say that but after that
experience with the the walk up to story
a three-story walk-up I'm done with it
you know it's amazing you know coming
through your books some of the stories
that you have and again the people that
you have writing on the back obviously
a-rod and Ron darling or are two gay
talese and George will have given praise
for I'm Keith Hernandez so for those who
are ready to crack this book open when
it's available in bookstores next May I
mean coming up next week in May what
what stories do you want them to take
away from this book about you Keith the
promise of this whole book was that a
lot of people have seen and
for me as the finished product when I
came to New York and I wanted them to
know that the struggles that I had and
it obviously it starts in my my very
young age when I first started playing
baseball and I was five all the good
times high school and then the minor
leagues where I struggled a couple years
in the minor leagues early and then in
the big leagues where I struggled my
first three years it took me a while to
to get going I was up in the big leagues
when I was twenty years old I was I was
two-and-a-half years removed from high
school and I'm up with the plate pinch
hitting against Tom Seaver in Busch
Stadium which I have in the book and
getting over the fact that not getting
over finally coming to the realization
that hey I'm a major leaguer I belong on
the same field with Pete Rose Willie
Stargell a Tom Seaver Steve Carlton I
belong on the field and I'm right there
with them and that was where we ended
the book in 1980 at the end of April
I've always had bad April's and I
finally after my MVP season in my
batting title season in 79 I'd never put
two seasons back-to-back and I've always
had a bad April except for 77 and after
that April when it when I've got to be
May 1st now sitting well over 300 and I
just they couldn't get me out that's
when I realized that was a major leaguer
and a pretty damn good one and that's
where the book ends so it's basically my
struggles and it wasn't easy with a lot
of hard times there's a lot of good
times but there are more downs and they
were up and I'm just the perseverance
and the will to be and try to be what I
wanted to be is my aspiration since I
was a little boy okay and then now in
terms of today's day and age Keith with
the Mets what happened to Matt Harvey
from your perspective Keith
well I think a lot of the surgeries did
him in I think that if he hadn't had the
you know he's had the two shoulders with
the butt and the thoracic and which no
one knows anything about it's it's a
it's an injury that's red that's rough
it's obvious to me what I saw this year
he's not the same pitcher he's not the
guy that's gonna throw 97 98 miles an
hour and throw a 92 mile an hour slider
anymore that may come back I don't know
but it's not there right now he has to
learn to pitch and I do think that he
made things a lot more difficult for him
you know you my dad always said yeah and
I may have this wrong you know you meet
the same people on the way down as you
do on the way up or is it on the way up
when they meet the same people on the
way down and boy the Sharks were
circling and he just he just made it
difficult for himself and then hopefully
it's been a humbling experience for him
you know it's okay to fail I failed that
makes you stronger you just say what did
what do you want to do you want to just
fold your tent and go away I'm fine and
do that then but are you gonna dig in
and say I'm gonna make it back and he's
got a noose he's got a new environment
now he's gonna be with the Reds I think
he needed to get out of New York and
start fresh and we'll see how he goes
and the Mets is a whole Mickey Calloway
at 11 and 1 and then you know obviously
the low-hanging fruit everyone likes to
make fun the back pages today in
particular pretty brutal about the
mixed-up lineup what can you say about
the the Mets this year so far Keith and
their chances to try and bounce back
this year well as good a two starters in
syndergaard and degrom at the top but he
goes on you know they can leave 32
starts a year that's only 64 games the
back end of the rotation hasn't lived up
to it Matz has struggled although he
threw good as last time
wheeler has struggled and he threw good
yesterday it was consistency Vargas has
been I pitched well at all and he's been
getting hammered
if they don't those three guys don't
pick it up it's going to be a tough haul
for the team it's a it gets a veteran
lineup they're not hitting right now I
think they will hit conforto has been
struggling it's a little bit baffling
for me I he's got such great talent
that's a beautiful swing you know but
it's a funny game you know and my life
kind of you look at my career early I
had a good year than a bad year then a
great year then you know so this is a
funny game and it's all a lot of it's
mental and that's what I try to put
forth in the book but I think if they
don't get that pitching from the
rotation the back end of that rotation
and I'm talking about three of them it's
going to be a tough haul for them but I
like the fact that we picked up mizerock
oh I think he I talked to him yesterday
he's healthy he's he's had those
surgeries on his both hips he said he's
never felt better
he really is wonderful behind a plate he
really kind of urged exhorted a wheeler
along yesterday and wheeler through
terrific so we'll see it's a long season
a no met fans go up and down and ready
to jump off a bridge and but it's a lot
of season left but they're gonna have to
get the pitching pitching always is the
name of the game Keith Congrats on the
book I know it's a certainly talking to
you and talking about how much you love
writing it's a labor of love something
that will be on the Shelf that
proverbial no one can ever take it away
from you I'm Keith Hernandez available
in bookstores on may fifteenth wherever
they are sold and I'd love to see
another one we're from 1980 on Seinfeld
the the 86 World Series and all that
good stuff Keith's research for that and
that's the idea the book would have been
way too long if we would have done my
whole life so we decided well ice is a
two and a half year process on this
blimp let alone so they wanted 90,000
words we ended it there this book dizzle
does well we're hopeful to do a sequel
what the second half of my career and
my life out of the game okay best of
[ __ ] Keith from all of us here he's
laying out in there and I hold my warmth
I love my master bathroom trust me he's
happy well well it doesn't exist unless
I see it on your Twitter account Keith I
got to tell you see a photograph send it
to Rich Eisen show will swell I want to
see it please I'll be great all right
I'll write that down I will I promise
okay Keith take care of congrats in the
book you got it back I'm Keith Hernandez
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience